NEIL: IT’S INCREDIBLE, I DON’T
KNOW HOW YOU KEEP UP WITH THE
NUMBERS.
AND HOW WITH US IS A JAVIER
LOBOS, THE CURRENT MAYOR.
AND IT SEEMS TO BE ACCELERATING
AGAIN THERE.
>> IT DOES.
MATTER OF FACT, THAT’S WHY --
LAST WEEK WE HAD TO DO A
TEMPORARY FACILITY RIGHT HERE
IN McALLEN BECAUSE THE--
IT’S DONE A CAPACITY OF 1200
AND THAT’S IT.
WE HAVE TO TAKE EMERGENCY
ACTION OTHERWISE 200 PLUS
POSSIBLY POSITIVE IMMIGRANTS
RELEASED INTO McALLEN, WE
COULDN’T DO THAT.
YES, WE DID -- WE BUILT A
COUPLE OF TENTS THE NEXT DAY
MOVED THEM TO WHAT YOU JUST SAW
IN MISSION, TEXAS.
SO WE HAVE AN ISSUE NOW, WE
HAVE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN
DONNA.
YOU GO TO THE WEST, AND NOW WE
HAVE MISSION AND THEN YOU GO TO
THE SOUTH AND WE HAVE THIS.
AND WE DO HAVE A MESS.
NEIL: AND TO PUT IT MILDLY,
WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT THE SPIKES
OF COVID CASES AMONG SOME OF
THE MIGRANTS, I’M SURE YOUR
RESIDENTS GET CONCERNED AS
WELL?
>> DEFINITELY.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THEY’VE
COME FROM POSITIVITY RATE OF 4
OR 5% TO NOW IN EXCESS OF 15%.
AND THAT’S ONE OF THE ISSUES WE
HAVE, TO GO THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY, IT’S BEEN INCREASING,
TOO.
WE CANNOT A--
TO THE IMMIGRANTS, WE’RE GOING
WHAT WE CAN TO KEEP OUR
RESIDENTS SAFE.
NEIL: YOU NEED MORE PERSONNEL.
ARE YOU GOING TO GET ANY?
>> NEIL, WE NEED EVERYTHING.
THAT’S WHY WE FILED A DISASTER
DECLARATION, BECAUSE WE CANNOT
BE DOING A FEDERAL JOB.
THIS IS NOT OUR RESPONSIBILITY,
WE’RE TRYING TO KEEP OUR PEOPLE
SAFE.
WE FILED A DECLARATION, WE NEED
FUNDS FROM THE STATE OR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DO WHAT
THEY’RE NOT DOING AND THAT KIND
OF ANGERS US BECAUSE IT’S A
CALLUS DISREGARD TO HAVE THE
BORDER PATROL JUST DROP OFF THE
IMMIGRANTS IN DOWNTOWN McALLEN.
NOW, WE LOVE OUR BORDER PATROL,
WE KNOW IT’S NOT THEIR FAULT
AND WE KNOW WHERE THE DIRECTION
COMES FROM AND THAT’S WHERE WE
PLACE BLAME.
NEIL: HANG IN THERE, MAYOR.
YOU’VE HAD YOUR HANDS FULL,